this is your sixth book I couldn't
believe it sixth book you must enjoy
writing I I this is the first book I
wrote because I wanted to write it not
because somebody said hey here's another
book deal and come up with a book which
wait so you wrote the other books just
to make some money is what you're saying
not my first one my first one I wrote on
my own but then you know you have a
successful book and they go hey do you
have another book and you're like sure
and then you know that so on and so
forth I got kind of stuck in that cycle
so this was the first book I've written
in like six years I really wanted to
write a book when I had something to say
yeah okay so this is a book where you
basically went to therapy and you just
go through sort of the evolution of what
you learned about yourself in therapy is
that right I went to a psychiatrist
after the election because I couldn't
have a bad I thought I was angry about
Donald Trump it turns out I was angry
about a lot of childhood stuff that was
unresolved my brother what if none of us
are mad at Donald Trump what if we're
all mad about our childhoods what
gorgeous confuse what if everyone's mad
about my child yeah the whole world
about my child could be possible other
therapies obviously working exactly no
my brother died when I was a young girl
and you know there's a lot of family
trauma that happened because of that not
just that after the aftermath of that of
course but I just always assumed that I
was too strong and too cool to ever have
to delve into real therapy like I
thought oh I'll never have to look at
that that part of myself plus in LA you
know everybody's into therapy is kind of
like silent retreats it was in my mind
and avocado and kale and all of that and
I was very hesitant to become one of
those people right right you will use
sort of her suspicions for the whole
process yes then you get into it and you
learn a lot about yourself for example
you decided once you'd gone into therapy
that you were way too impatient and
judgmental right so I and he you know he
had to give me a lot of examples I would
go off on people if they didn't do what
I liked I'm sure you've seen that happen
with me you know I didn't if I would I
was very judgy and I would
no patience and so like what give me an
example of like in just in everyday life
because I'm fascinated by this I've
talked to many people who said oh my
life changed I'm a different person now
do you think are you really almost like
the last time you really lost it and got
irritated well I have a group with this
week I was on on tour for my book so I
was going to Clearwater Florida
I was already a little bit like
Clearwater Scientologists like you know
so I get on the plane and there's a guy
there and he's a big you know kind of
Floridian okay and that's a nicest way
to describe someone from Florida he is a
Floridian so I get on the plane and I'm
sitting next to him and I was like okay
you know and I now I meditate and I do
breathing exercises so I never am rude
to people ever I try not to be obviously
I'm not perfect but he started farting
on the plane he farted a time duct tape
you don't say shut up to someone who
farted no I would have turned him around
face down and been like shut out - yeah
five years ago I love that there's an
exact count yeah tire had a clicker my
eyes were closed and I was like oh no no
no no that can't be happening this is
gonna this is terrible this is terrible
and I was like no Chelsea this is a
human being
obviously he's sick or something
Isaac just breathe breathe and then I'm
like breathing and I'm like no don't
breathe that's his body don't breathe it
you know an oxygen mask will deploy